In Indonesia, the Attorney General confirms the execution of eight drug traffickers,...
...including seven foreigners.
In Togo, election authorities declare incumbent President Faure Gnassingbe...
...the provisional winner of the country's latest presidential election.
In the United States, Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe and President Obama...
...toast to bilateral relations at a White House state dinner...
...the evening before Abe will address a joint meeting of Congress.
In Yemen, the Saudi-led coalition bombed the Sanaa airport...
...to prevent an Iranian plane from landing.
And finally from Saudi Arabia, King Salman bin Abdulaziz shuffles top leaders...
...in a decree naming a new crown prince, foreign prime minister and deputy crown prince.